okay what about janice sorry what about
julian barber the janice oh julian yeah
now i haven't had a chance to read his
book i started reading it but i don't
know what his theory is i think as far
as i got was just the history of
thermodynamics so what is the janus
point what is his theory on time and
then obviously compare and contrast with
yours
so a few coordinates here
first of all julian it's a fantastic
historian of science he wrote a big
thick scholarly book on the history of
mechanics which is a total masterpiece
in my opinion
um
then he
it's known for two ideas about time one
uh
which is uh several
that's is mostly known for that
uh
some time ago um
his uh
idea that we should think uh at
the world in a completely timeless
way just a distribution probability as
instantaneous
configurations
and recently he came out with a new idea
uh
which is this janus point
so uh i distinguish
three barbers
bubbles the bibles the historian of
physics and which you know chapel as the
french say i mean infinite uh respect of
him i learned so much from him
um barbara as the guy denying uh time in
the sense of uh
his old book on time and the third bible
which is about this giants point
so
the second one
i was never convinced much because he
had a
complicated story about the universe
being extended in space but not in time
uh
which i did not find convincing i we
could go into that uh but this
we should not talk about that and we
should talk about the third one
and the third one this janus point idea
it's indeed
quite
intriguing
he's not the only one who has been
recently talking about sean carroll has
also
consider this idea there's there's an
increasing attention to this idea
and the idea is that um
uh
we are wrong
when we say that generically
if you take a system
generically most solutions of this
equation of motion is in equilibrium so
there's no past and future
um
it's true that if you if
you put the gas in a box and you close
it
with a fixed amount of energy
uh
most possible solutions or where the gas
goes in long time is in equilibrium and
in equilibrium the entropy is constant
there's no past and future
so then we have to say why the entropy
was low in the past it seems strange
the point is that the universe is not
like a gas in a box that's the main
observation that also sounds like when
we were talking about that there are
some problems with applying our limited
scale physics or when we do experiments
to the universe as a whole i think
that's where i got it from was reading
the janus point he was saying the
universe is not a box so you can't apply
the same laws of thermodynamics to the
universe as a whole yes exactly so but
there's a specific very very specific
reason for which you cannot
that uh
there is no equilibrium state because uh
uh if you think about the imagine the
universe just a bunch of particles in an
infinite space okay
they can spread forever
okay so they never get too real
uh
to a real equilibrium
so let's consider one possible
configuration okay
of this particle okay a generic one they
would just move somehow maybe they come
close at some point and then they
disperse
so if you look at the future they
disperse if you come back there's some
moment in which they're closer and then
they disperse again
so the entropy in that configuration
okay
it's up goes to a minimum and then grows
of course there's no preferred direction
of time because you know both directions
disperse
but there's a minimum
so if you're on one side the entropy is
growing like that if you're on the other
side
like that so we just have one side and
of course the entropy is growing right
if you think a mountain
any mountains it has you know one
direction which is down and the other
direction which is up so generically
there's always one direction down with
one direction up
so the idea is well maybe we got
confused about the model of the gas in
the box and the equilibrium forget the
equilibrium maybe the right way
is thinking that generically
histories possible history of the world
evolve in some way and necessarily there
is one point which is minimal entropy
and then
it goes one side and the other this is
the core updating maybe i'm
oversimplifying it a little bit but
that's a coral idea
so um
there are some questions about that
there are some possible doubts i'm not
sure is
it's really a solution of the
of of the end of of which problem of the
problem why the entropy is low in the
past
this you know
why the time is oriented because in the
in the past it was law entropy so why in
the past of this law entropy
that's
an attempt
to answer that question
there is something ringing very
interesting and i think there's a
discussion going on right now
among theoretical physicists and
philosophers
uh on
should we buy this argument is it
correct um
i'm interested in the discussion
and i i hope that in some years it will
clean up
namely yes that's a good way of of
thinking
about uh why entropy was low in the past
one direction which is the one we call
the past uh or
no come on we're getting confused about
probabilities here
you're it's you such tissues squeezing
in some some
some
some intuition which is not correct i
don't know it's a it's it's um
it's relatively recent
that
we've been thinking about that
and uh i'm open to to this idea i found
it interesting
this minimum point does he say that's
the big bang or does the big bang happen
at somewhere on the up so it's still
relatively easy yeah in a sense that in
a sense that's what's called the janus
point because genesis is god
in in rome it's it's latin god
um which is the god of the doors of the
of the change of the ear it has two two
faces it was always
uh represented with a head with two
faces one face is this way one faces the
other way
so the janus point is a point where the
future you know the one future this way
one future that way because uh
the future is determined by end to be
growing so this is the minimum of the
entropy so
entropy goes this way and it goes this
way so whoever is here or whenever you
are here you see the future this way
whenever here you see the future this
way so you always see the uh
the big bang in the past right that's
what you call the past